how's it going everybody it's lauren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today
things are getting so exciting tom
holland has finally shared his first
official video directly from himself for
spider-man 3. we knew that production
for spider-man 3 had started but now tom
holland is on
the set we already knew that the
production crew was on set the builders
of the set were of course there working
on it tom holland's stunt devil was even
sharing videos of him performing stunts
as well for spider-man 3 but now we
finally have confirmation that tom
holland
is indeed in atlanta and he shared a
video with us
exclaiming how excited he is and we're
going to dive right into this video but
first a big congratulations to youtube
user dark
cable 59 hoppy for being last week's
funko pop
iron spider man giveaway winner email me
in the email in my description and
we'll get you your prize and let's keep
it going this week with another
spider-man funko since things are
getting so exciting this week is going
to be the imposter
spider-man funko pop just subscribe like
the video leave a comment down below to
enter
so not only do we have this video today
but we also have some news about
spider-gwen
possibly making a cameo in spider-man 3
which we'll talk about after but let's
show the video
okay so we just landed in atlanta
and
it's time for spider-man 3 let's go
so short but sweet but also officially
confirming that tom holland is in
atlanta at marvel studios and filming is
starting
and of course you know what that means
once the filming process has begun
we get leaks we get leaked photos leaked
videos sometimes some parts of the
script get leaked
in fact i'm surprised tom holland didn't
just spoil the actual title of the movie
right then and there in that video
let's go our boys growing up i'm so
proud but of course there's still a
while till the movie comes out there's
plenty of time for him to spoil things
and we do have a confirmation from a
sony executive that we are getting our
first
look at spider-man 3 before the end of
the year so a teaser for spider-man 3
incoming in just a couple of months so
filming for spider-man 3
is about to happen tom holland is on set
and we also have another big report
today as i mentioned about spider-gwen
and this is coming from daniel richmond
daniel has already released some scoops
about spider-man 3.
and today according to his patreon
account he says that he has heard
emma stone might return for the
spider-verse type of movie that is going
to happen in spider-man 3 and they are
planning on having her
in spider-man 3 as spider-gwen
now spoiler alert if you have not seen
the amazing spider-man 2
pretty big spoiler coming up so you
should click away now now of course for
those of us who have seen it we know
that she
dies at the end of the amazing
spider-man 2. so this makes you wonder
when exactly are they going to go
into these other different universes to
get these different characters now of
course we are dealing with
the multiverse the universes that go
into our alternate universes so
it doesn't necessarily mean she's coming
from the actual amazing spider-man
universe because she does indeed die
in that universe but that does not mean
that there's not another
alternate universe in which she has
fully embraced and become
spider-gwen andrew garfield may not be
spider-man
in that universe but she is spider-gwen
and this could be the spider-gwen that
we see in spider-man 3.
now we have so many characters rumored
to be in this movie at this point in
time there's another rumor that kirsten
dunst could be reprising her role as mj
and there's another rumor that we could
even be getting harry osborn from the
amazing spider-man universe as well
and with so many characters being
rumored you have to wonder how exactly
they're going to fit them all into the
movie
well i have a theory because spider-man
3 still does need to be about r peter
parker it doesn't need to be about
20 different characters yes seeing all
these characters would be epic the
spider-verse being set up is definitely
going to be something that everybody has
been wanting for such a long time
but i do think it's going to be just
that i think it's going to be a
setup for the spiderverse i think that
doctor strange is going to show our
peter parker from the main mcu timeline
other different universes while
mentoring peter parker
because we know that doctor strange is
going to be peter's new
mentor type figure and we know that
spider-man is going to be in a lot of
trouble
so perhaps doctor strange shows peter
parker different spider-man universes to
show him that it's not just him
but in almost every other alternate
universe spider-man
and other versions of spider-man have
their hands full
it's not an easy job to be spider-man
it's not something that you can just do
and everything is okay all the time
i think that we're probably going to see
something very similar to this
and then by the end of the movie the
actual real-life spider-verse is going
to be established i think we'll
definitely get cameos from toby maguire
andrew garfield and some other
characters as well from their
universes but then we will get at the
end of the movie a setup for
new spider-man entirely a new miles
morales a new spider-gwen and possibly
jessica drew as well we do know that
olivia wilde is going to be directing
a spider-woman type of film rumored to
be in the mcu in some way shape or form
so i think there's no doubt that the
spider-verse is coming it's going to be
set up in spider-man 3 however
i do think that the multiverse is going
to play a little bit more of a minor
role in spider-man 3 and still
focus on r peter parker which of course
it is his movie
and is what he deserves but be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spiderverse news i'll
update you if i hear anything
and again super exciting tom holland has
shared his first video about spider-man
3 which means we are going to be getting
more
very very soon so let me know how
excited you are about spider-man 3
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
wolf wolf
you